so moving on Japanese games a lot of
japanese game dramatic stories press
conference japan star ocean 5 they're
making a new RPG under their new studio
called Tokyo RPG factory not only named
but I want to talk about to specifically
I want to talk about before I get to my
magnum opus uh we're getting a mere
sequel uh near was a very weird very
strange very brash game a spin-off of
the drakengard series on made by an
eccentric fellow by the name of yo
kitaro who doesn't like to show his face
in public which is why it showed up in a
weekly I'd ask he did a talk at GDC last
year and he did his entire talk with a
paper with a paper mask over his face
this is a character from near which is
really funny it's kind of like the moon
really like the memes that have come out
of his appearance um my saddest
character in near the saddest character
they're all sad but this is definitely
the saddest what's interesting about
about near not only that we're getting
one which is sort of strange never
thought we could a sequel it's being
made by platinum games no platinum games
has a full slate right now they've got
scalebound they've got the starter
starfox transmission and in transformers
so this is the fourth game we've seen or
heard of from them in the past few
months that they're working on and I
guess square approached platinum to give
a new life to near and put some sort of
action RPG element yeah what do you what
do you guys think Kevin you reviewed
mirror I did I was one of those people
that did wasn't actually very keen on
their III got I got bored after a while
like large stretches with not a whole
lot going on I like near as an idea more
than I did as an actual game that makes
sense um but that's kind of why I'm
excited about near too because I think
this is a chance for those ideas to
really make you know really come to
fruition yeah I mean the fact that
they're doing is a clear sign that even
Square Enix who has been which has been
kind of like tone deaf and blind to the
demands and and what their fans one is
giving me a second chance like that is
the most obscure JRPG probably in the
last ten years and it didn't make much
of a buzz I mean a very small niche
enjoy to the fact that they've actually
decided or we should make a second
near yeah it's kind of encouraging so
and hopefully it's got it doesn't have
that money because it wasn't as popular
there's not a lot of like ties to the
original to plan and really go wild with
it what kind of a sense of the tone or
the world did you get from this trailer
I mean it have any clues in that concept
up so I the girl with the white hair
there were some characters with white
hair in the original near which is why
I'm wondering if maybe they're connected
the thing about the drakengard in the
near games is that they're they're weird
in their strange drakengard 3 which came
out last year the main character was a
like escaped prostitute with like magic
powers near of their main characters you
find out throughout the game that one of
the main characters a girl it was
actually born intersex and it's sort of
tortured or her whole life you have the
father-daughter relationship which is
not something you see in a lot of games
these games have never shied away from
being sexy from using foul language from
being just really in your face and dirty
and gross and I get a sense from this
that maybe it will I mean maybe this
will also go down that same path when
she went down you had the nice upskirt
shot which is I mean we made it what 45
minutes before we got an upskirt shot
maybe yeah um but I think me I'm
guessing that this year will be the same
kinda make the same post-apocalyptic
kind of unafraid to be mature vibe I'm
getting from it is it seems like Square
Enix if I was to put myself in their
shoes I'd be thinking along the lines of
persona and thinking we want something
that's kind of quirky and unique and
eye-catching in the same way that
atlases RPGs are because I mean the
persona games are hella Japanese like
mad Japanese so Japanese but like there
is such a buzz like a worldwide buzz
people I excited for persona a few years
ago nobody would care about it cuz it's
you know called shin megami tensei yeah
so it's like they want to recapture some
of that kind of weird japanese niche
taking it across you know the borders
and making it palatable more interesting
so doing that weird quirky stuff with it
and letting platinum really go wild and
indulge your weird fantasies might be a
way to kind of represent near something
fresh and interesting you have to be
really careful here though because a big
part of near is constantly changing of
gameplay styles yeah that game had you
know text adventure and it had Resident
Evil going through the mansion all
creepy yep and it had schmuck
you were you were in a side-scrolling
warmer inside scrolling platformer and
just you need to me you need to have
that otherwise it's not near the other
thing you need to have is the most
stupendous soundtrack I've ever heard
yes i still think near is i think near
is possibly one of you know the greatest
soundtracks are created for a game and I
don't say that lightly next door so no
three it's cool I don't know how but I
got so much so that's really what we
need we need a great soundtrack and we
need we need that yes League I agree
gameplay styles I agree alright that is
near to made by platinum we still don't
have a release date they're going to
talk more about it in fall 2015 I'm
guessing TGS let us know if you think
near should be getting a sequel in the
comments below as always